AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME, "SEX
MACHINA."
IN JUST 12 DAYS AND 23 AND A
HALF HOURS, "TERMINATOR GENYSIS"
IS COMING OUT.
CINEMATIC SAGA OF KILLER CYBORGS
WILL CONTINUE FOR A NEW
GENERATION.
BUT THERE'S ACTUALLY A SCARIER
SCENARIO INVOLVING SENTIENT
ROBOTS THAT WE JUST HEARD ABOUT
IN THE "NEW YORK TIMES," TALKING
SEX DOLLS.
ICK.
THE CREATOR OF THE REALDOLL HAS
JUST ADDED ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE TO HIS CREEPY
SILICONE WOMAN-FORMS.
SO NOW, FOR JUST $10,000, THE
MOST SOCIALLY AWKWARD MEN ON THE
PLANET CAN PRETEND TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WHILE THEY PRETEND
TO HAVE SEX.
>> I HOPE TO BECOME THE WORLD'S
FIRST SEX ROBOT.
>> IS SHE ENJOYING THIS?
DOES SHE LIKE MAKING ME FEEL
THIS?
>> OH!
OH, MY GOD.
>> CHRIS: COME TO ME IF YOU WANT
TO JIZZ.
SOON THESE ROBOTS ARE GOING TO
GAIN ENOUGH INTELLIGENCE TO
REALIZE THEY SHOULD DUMP THESE
LOSERS, SO COMEDIANS,
I WANT YOU TO GIVE ME AS MANY
ROBOT BREAKUP LINES AS YOU CAN
IN 60 SECONDS.
>> IF YOU TOUCH ME AGAIN I'M
GOING TO CALL THE ROBOCOPS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
HANNAH.
>> I HAVE MET SOMEONE ELSE.
HE'S A ROOMBA SEX GOD.
>> CHRIS: MATT.
>> I CAN NO LONGER DEAL WITH THE
PATHETIC TICKLES YOU CALL SEXUAL
THRUSTS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
HANNAH.
>> IT'S NOT YOU, IT'S WINDOWS
M.E..
>> CHRIS: OH, MY GOD!
IT'S ( BLEEP ) BRILLIANT!
OH, HANNAH.
MWA!
CHRIS.
>> BUFFERING.
( LAUGHTER )
>> I'M SO SORRY
I COULD NOT BE BETHANY.